are humans the only species that can
learn to decipher those special stimuli
that are so familiar to us printed words
to examine this we taught a group of
baboons to discriminate real English
words from nonsense strings of letters
which we will call non words and doing
this was only possible because of the
extraordinary research facility
developed by co-author Joelle beigel or
behavioral experiments with baboons
there are 10 testing booths indicated on
one side of a large enclosure and so
boone's can freely enter a testing booth
take part in an experiment and quit when
they feel like it each booth is equipped
with a touchscreen that's used to
present the test stimuli and to record
responses and a food dispenser to
deliver award after each correct
response but baboons are identified by a
microchip implanted in each arm a
computer then launches a particular
testing program initiating a new
experiment or picking up with a baboon
left off the last time this unique
facility allows us to collect data for
several thousands of trials per baboon
each day in optimal conditions with no
stress to the animal certainly reading
is one of the most complex skills that
humans have to learn and in languages
like English and French we read these
words via their component letters that
is we use information about which
letters of we're in the word in order to
recognize it but perhaps this is only
part of the story there might be some
other predisposition toward letter based
reading that has nothing to do with
language in our experiment baboons first
saw a string of four letters on the
screen touched that stimulus in order to
initiate the trial and then had to touch
an oval shape on the screen of the
letters formed a real English word or a
cross shape if the letters were not a
real
the key to success in training babu's to
discriminate between real words and non
words is that each new word the baboon
had to learn was repeatedly presented
intermixed with different non words so
the baboon learned to respond
differently to the repeated stimulus our
star baboon Dan learned to respond
correctly to more than 300 words in
about six weeks of training and
approximately 50,000 trials here we can
see how accuracy of responding to two
words and two non words evolves as a
function of training for the six baboons
tested in our study we measured the
orthographic distance between each
non-word and the set of words that a
baboon had learned who use the standard
edit distance that measures the number
of changes that is letter deletions
letter insertion substitutions and
transpositions reported transform them
onward into real word now on this graph
here we can see how the greater the
orthographic distance between the non
word and was known to the bones the
easier it was to respond that this
stimulus was an awkward accuracy
increasing as a function of automatic
distance and on the right here we see
the same linear relation between
accuracy in responding to long words and
orthographic distance between the non
words and words known to human subjects
they take this as evidence that our
baboons were using orthographic
information that is information about
letter identities and letter positions
in order to accurately discriminate real
words from non words in other words we
have evidence for a predisposition
toward letter based reading that is not
linguistically based and not even
specific to humans